in the midst of movie and TV show reactions
Le such a busy schedule around here who's got
time to prep gourmet meals well that's where
Factor steps in Factor America's number one
ready to eat meal kit delivering fresh never
frozen meals right to your door take a look at
Factor's Gourmet plus lineup the three bean vegan
chili a symphony of toasted spices and veggies
and the coconut lime curry tofu it's tropical
and tantalizing all the Gourmet feels ready in
Just 2 minutes about diving into some roasted
veggie and pesto tortillini perfectly roasted
veggies with cheese tortillini all draped in
a creamy basil spinach pesto salivating just
pling that footage back now while I'm a plant
powered individual I got the Mother-in-law
staying with us right now so with that in mind
for those who fancy Meats the sun dried tomato
chicken and black pepper and sage pork chop are
Rave worthy the Factor's Gourmet plus even my
hectic days get a gourmet touch no more grocery
runs just pure deliciousness so you're ready to
elevate your food game reject Nation jump
in to factor75.com or click below with real
rex50 you're in for a 50% off treat with your
first box dive into the Gourmet life people
all right guys we got ourselves Loki season
dose episode dose today John how are you I'm
an Ora boros of excitement G coyi I am dosed
up and ready yeah all right use two do ladies
and gentlemen leave a like on this video be sure
to subscribe click the notification Bell to get
notified when reaction for episode 3 is up here
on the channel cuz you know we're going to be
covering all of Loki season 2 also we've been
covering gen V go ahead check that out as well
we got two great comic book shows airing on the
same day that's crazy and of course um I want to
say a massive thank you to all who have joined
our patreon via the shows and movies that we've
been covering lately and Loki is one of those
so full length through AC and watch along where
you syn with your own copy of Loki available for
our super sexy rejects over at our patreon page
we also cover several shows over there where
there are reaction highlights and watch along
exclusively included right now let's just get
into Loki I'm excited to continue this journey
that's who built this place that's who's coming
back she was going to kill him Sy where is she
I don't know it looks like a 70 tor I haven't
heard that yet thoughts no sy's not here just
hop to we got a hit on a 10 pad that belonged to
Hunter X5 before it went dark like how they went
to the 70s with Doc and X5 not responding this
our only lead zaniac yeah Rafael Cassel is a
wolf is that supposed to be like uh Joe Spinell
and Maniac oh that's cool X5 isn't actor now or
he's under cover looks pretty real for me M
variants are original undercover how do you
feel about your meteoric rise to F I don't know
how I feel but I know it look pretty darn good
come on look at this there be a zaniac 2 no sequel
for the fans Mobius W no I used to work with this
guy he's a friend from work you look great thank
you very much you look pretty good yourself feel
like we're in Zoolander again that hansel's so hot
right now Hansel is he running now he is running
oh no no you're at the zaniac premiere can
I get your autograph anything for whoa nice
v15 he's a superstar running down the streets
yeah how long has he been under cover at least
take your Ascot off man come on Mobius
you're going to ruin my life here your
life here oh that's right Loki has powers he's
a God we so glad we're here God those Ruffles
though let's get a Warner Runner
little Tom Cruz run for Tom
Heston again just nice to see actual
sets and long enough takes to tell
what's happening they went on location to the
70s this says a mission impossible Vibe it really
is come on X5 did you really think you
could outrun me are you known for your
agility hi where's the rude boy off to is
the fancy going off the L whoa did you L take
a oh he's going to get jumped by The Sex Pistols
back up back up hey back up oh he did the twirl oh
you're the tough guy [Music] huh sophisticated
X5 of course you doing your own stunts
now you quit with the magic and fight
fair yes stop [Music] running nice the
Shadows a this is great right
from the comics that's great
yeah shadow people feel like we
barely got to see Loki use his
powers last season little over the
top don't you think all the shadow
play I thought it was spot on that's
the real Loki y we haven't seen Loki
be mischievous in a bit I know missed
it it's like a superpowered agent
now you he's a full on t vaa agent now you
will tell us if you found Sylvie right cuz
I'm a criminal right okay come on get in
there what a fascinating time Jump to go
from the last episode to this hunt him down now
he's a criminal I feel like we're missing some
stuff is he tiny oh just working Obie could
I get you to take a look at this temp pad
interesting do you think this is a higher
priority than preventing a temporal meltdown
everything you need to know about this I wrote
about it in here I love him when are they going
to start selling those TVA handbooks 6 months
later like the Ant-Man book oh I need them R
Slayer killed C20 attempted to kill mobus threw
me in time jail and tried to take over the TVA why
would tracking her temp pad be a secret recap
right Shout It Out Eugene R Slayer erased the
data from her temp Pad but I was able to piece
together who sent the last message and who was
that should man with the system is that with the
red light cuz we tried that already I'll try it
again cuz I don't think you had that pressed back
did you too complicated chish here what to help
you focus if we don't work this out this entire
place is going to be destroyed temporal meltdown
this feels like a office workplace kind of show
as well now yeah very quickly when I was in the
past Ren Slayer and he who remains it sounded
like they were Partners she really is full of
surprises that she just gets progressively
more vexed what is that it's just a a rigged
temp pad X5 says it somehow blocks TVA tracking
that's not what it does oh my God yes you are
more essential MVP this definitely doesn't block
any trackers that's for sure how are they going
to fix that super easy barely an inconvenience
give it to Casey let's take a run up Brad wolf
now it's going to be a cop show Brad knows us
and he knows our tactics but that's what makes
for an interesting chess match okay most of all
Brat's an [__] love how he's looking forward
to interrogating cool oh welcome back reflection
at the top too start treating me like somebody
who outranks you I don't work here oh that's
a good point you should stop talking it Blocks
Your trackers no it doesn't yeah no [__] what
is it designed for X5 it's Brad weren't you the
one blabbering on and on about how we all had
lives I went down and got my life what exactly
are you mad at me about oh my God this changes
everything so broken now you're just trying
to make up for all the terrible awful [__]
you've done in your life you pathetic little
man character Arc setup keep going I wanted
to hit more good oh you're good Loki see I've
read your file it's you file you're the problem
it's you're the problem it's you you think you're
special but you're not doesn't matter what outfit
you put on play dress up or little lies you tell
come on Loki's black widowing him you just make
effort everything worse for Mobius for B15 for
your mother oh why did you say that a trying to
be a hero man you're a villain ooh do [Laughter]
that thank you Brad I have done
some terrible awful things and
maybe that is who I AMS going he
knows is he bad cop now a loser
always happen always will be for
all time always and perhaps I've
been holding something back oh perhaps I've just
been waiting for a moment like this look how puffy
those lapels are so let's try this one more time
where is Sylvie you're way too obsessed with her
he needs therapy control your little pet Mobius I
got a little tense hey you want to hear a good one
knock knock who Z Mobius Brad Brad who that's show
this and I don't want that to happen to you we
get you back down there so they don't forget about
you how's that sound you would do that amazing you
seeing this Mobius you could be an actor I'm not
an actor I'm an analyst but thank you you could
be a jety commercial So Meta I mean who even are
you on the timeline do you know I think it does
matter because none of this is real well okay I
can't wait to find that out Mobius isn't even your
real name well it's what I answer to do you have
any idea what her Expressions this whole scene you
know they took our lives and you're still here
I mean it's kind of weird man I mean you need
to wake up Brad is controlling this you need to
wake aw is you're nothing she's nothing I don't
even know where to start with that but you're oh
until you wake up you're just a nowhere man you're
a silly little man silly little did he just Will
Smith him I think he did yeah keep my existences
name out your oh my God Mobius is a Will Smith
variant then keep my noname out of your mouth
he didn't get under my skin he got under your
skin are you all right I've never seen you like
this before see me like what it's okay I'm not
judging the longest chain of file cabinets where
are we I was following you no I was following
you how was that possible he was in front you
were clearly ahead of me how about slice of pie
hell yeah nothing pie can't fix key lime key lime
pie back to first season a throwback has a
reference ref steg are rewarding me for knowing
a thing I paid attention it's really good it is
I'm so impressionable now I want pie it's the only
pie they have here listen that wasn't tactical I
lost it what you remember that time I was so angry
with my father and my brother I went down to earth
and I held the whole of New York City hostage not
just that you murdered a bunch of people tried to
use the mindstone on Tony star it didn't work so
I threw him off the building let me tell you
something wasn't [Music] tactical sometimes
our emotions get the better of us you are the
therapist Loki you never wanted to visit your
place on the timeline or did you don't you want to
see the life you're supposed to live before they
kidnapped you and brought you into the TVA not
really come on you know you do it's not my life
but it could have been it isn't this is this is
a great reversal of the dynamic of season 1 I'm
even sitting across the he's like relaxed I get
it you might think twice and case something bad
or something good something bad I can handle what
if it's something good oh so despondent what if
he goes to Earth and finds he lives in a jet ski
Factory oh they sporks good observation the most
futuristic utensil Easter egg sport he found her
maybe didn't turn her in he wants to continue to
live his best life on the timeline he wants more
time to be Brad wolf Brad wolf is pretty sick just
got to make him talk well come on you're the god
of Mischief right I love how this is like the time
is a flat circle production design throughout
it even this pie room and the circles above
them in a big circle even though it was like
two different shots it's like looks the exact
[Music] same what oh no oh jeez what
does that even mean whoa the vampire
oh time to get mischievous hi please
the door open so confident going to
try the hard ball tactics this time uh
something like that okay punch him in the
nuts what is
this oh yeah interesting to put it in his
POV yeah that was cool you have information
inform you don't want to give it to us so how
do we find common ground you going to suck all
the arrows room which one of you came up
with this little script May's controller
can't start the festivities without that
little baby stand by it's all part of the
bit what exactly is this thing supposed
to be I don't know but I'm very curious
hey open up good act guys perfect there is
actually one other option no no hey commit
more to it Mobius come on sell it that thing
does not work without the controller though
this one okay great we're going to have a
little yeah get worried did you find Sylvie
simple question really doesn't mean we can't
enjoy ourselves as we go along I hope Loki
does something truly bad I'm not trying to be
a hero bride I'm a villain remember no Loki M
you got to sell this better hey L you're not a
villain now he's actually worried earlier I said
some really hurtful thing you don't know what
you're doing with that what does this one do
whoa oh yes samam sorry uh could hurt
yourself there I guess there's a learning
curve with this thing right yeah there
is a learning curve you know you could
kill me with that could I do appreciate
good Rhythm and seam workor there you
go let me try this let me try this
W all right sorry that's only made it smaller
I've done some terrible awful things yeah you
have you're doing one right now well okaying at
it I swear I don't know where they are ride what
a cruel way to crush someone I want to believe
you but you're just you're such a good actor I
lied I was supposed to go look for syv I bailed I
didn't buy it w wa dude I went down there I went
to get my life none of this is real well if none
of this is real I guess you aren't either whoa
dude who wa I'll tell you where she
is she has a new life the plan worked
so they found Sylvia and they just let her
live yeah but I found her first she's on a
branch little bit of Mischief I as good as your
plan thank you I bought it you did that last bit
not the beginning I thought it the end I did he's
a good analyst actor anal actor X-Men it's got to
be hey OB this is Casey I I thought I could
help die KC o it's meant to be going to die
ni nice to meet you we're all going to die did
you try the C12 bypass pathway that won't work
are you sure of course I wrote it Dad you wrote
the TVA guide book you've read it practically
memorized it will you sign mine you signed
my guide yeah just next to your picture hold
on containment do are locked only the person
who designed it can open it with a Life Scan
of his temporal Aura yeah yeah and he's dead
so without Miss Min to help us override the
lock we're stuck where is she we have to
convince a rogue artificial intelligence
to come back to work we got to do it fast see
what happens Disney I'll built the device but
you need to find a way in or it won't matter
a miss m is busy designing the secret Invasion
credits you go ahead I'm going to head on back
all right wait wait wait wait why are you so
jumpy it's making me nervous I'm not jump I'm not
nervous yeah you're like you you want to take off
little bits of psychology are great stressed
m is this all the time I have to find out what
she know just twitching in the background
I'll do the talking be ready he so agitated
can you refill the straw when you get a SI
I've already done it I don't know Sylvia I
know you want a normal sea this seems like
the most boring thing this is that's what
you want to think textbook normal try
all of it look how my gold stars she
has this feels tense I'm not going
anywhere to try get some apple pie
he's going to be like 30 lbs heavier
by the end of this season so much
pie like the rendition on their
music listen I haven't got all
day are you going to order something or
what can we talk my break's in 5 minutes
perfect how lucky perfect man knows
how to travel through time talk fast
got to fill that drink up you work
here why are you so resistant towards
him she got a green truck she still loves him
Sylvie I was in the future and I saw you the
TVA is in danger and you were there I need to
know why but this factor is into why look as
much as I'd love to see the TVA burnt to the
ground I have no intention of going back there
my life's here now we got a whole new haircut it's
going to happen is it that sounds a lot like the
future's already been written we both know that
it hasn't not anymore I made sure of that free
will baby Sy if you and I don't work together on
this I can't guarante here with your TVA [__]
this is tense this is bigger than the TVA this
is about everything all time always the TVA is
the only defense what I saw of you is true then
there's nothing that stands between this world
and utter destruction so was it that Sylvie who
pruned him I still think he pruned himself you
were setting us up for an ambush hell you were
just set setting us up for a great meal what is
happening right now they're just it's like they're
going over every detail of their relationship
that has ever happened why complicated bot to
unpack when you're basically in a relationship
with yourself you say opposites attract no this
is such a great flourish can we just talk for a
second about how crazy life is I mean 10 minutes
ago you were screaming at me you're nothing and
now here we are enjoying a meal like gentlemen you
slap me in the face I'm not going to C you a shake
okay just enjoy this tell me about zaniacs
you don't care about my movie Brad I saw the
poster it looked scary it's not scary it's
elevated Thriller yes yes Cinema thank you
very much it's an 824 movie you got to get
your own tickets I'm not hooking you up for
this I will this feels improvised I love
them so much why don't we just get this
to go how about that it it packs right
up and we get out of here get me back to
the sacred timeline it's like although
now it's just get me out of here which
is is this a setup oh what's going on yep
nothing oh man oh no you just going to give
everyone Free Will and walk away that's the
way it works I am God sorry to interrupt I think
Brad's got something that he might want to get
off his chest zaniac is getting a sequel and
you're both invited we stay here we're all going
to die they're going to die orange shirt she's
going to die we are all going to die this unless
whoa they're going to bomb every Branch yeah
including this one okay that theory is true
I'll show you the 15 incom hey right back into
the uniform now she's got a reason to go to the
TVA we need to know where this attack is coming
from call is coming from inside the house she's
going to kill them all start tracking those
charges that's a cool way to do that reveal
oh my God like a video game yeah portal they've
proven 30% of the branches Mobius they're killing
billions take dots down now this feels like a
video game Mission that's how they're bombing
all the timelines at once they're all connected
to that central control panel that's our Target
it really does okay d set up what you can shut
up docs she wants time Freedom damn there's too
many I'm going to call OB OB is overworked as it
is you're going to get a stomach cramp from the
McDonald's oh boy don't overthink
it oh yeah they could it's Grace to
bring that back make magic together
how much damage is already done though is
this all of Doc's loyalist everyone who
didn't an escape Mobius you should come
back OCC that quickly episode 2 mission
accomplished oh
nice oh oh all right we're at the end of episode
button I'm afraid of what's about to
happen take me back to McDonald's w
it's literally like looking at a
Lifeline those are people those are lives
oh oh they're probably going to get Victor
timley to get some help that'd be interesting
[Music] yeah she with Victor timely is
this the best you not can do there was
nothing we could do some defense wof
TVA is the problem it's broken it's
rotten don't it's harded you
can't fix the institution from
[Music] within this is a remarkable
advertisement for McDonald's really
is working next time we're at the TVA
the sacred timeline will just be golden
arches true timeline do you think you'll
be in tomorrow though yeah cool cool no
is your mom on her way to pick you
up uh she'll be here I'm good oh he
crushing make a choice you have free will to
choose oh are you a hero or a villain let's
talk about it guys let's talk about it all
righty guys well you're listening to us on
Apple or Spotify we uh just watched Loki season
2 episode 2 we're going to talk about right now
please rate the video uh but before we do that
oh ladies and gentlemen um thank you again to
everyone who has been buying some reject apparel
at www. reation shop.com um I'm finally wearing
this one this is RR this like the ratings great
really comfortable I got a different color feel
like Iain get the black ones we are full of
language uh bad jokes and nipple chills and
then we also got uh we're selling these as well
these Marvel inspired t-shirts as well not Marvel
Inspire they're just straight up Marvel right here
it's like a lowy tarot card and John's all decked
out but of course we got other ones like our
recently launched Ahsoka snip snip shirt if you
know you know and then we got our child protection
services sure as I like to call it and you know we
just got a whole bunch more and we are creatively
involved in them ourselves so thank you guys one
of the absolute best ways to support the channel
is by rocking some RR merch showing you are a true
citizen of the reject Nation but yeah guys let's
kick it off all right let's do this uh let's go
Coy what would you rate it out of 10 out of 10
this episode seven yeah okay John like uh 7.8 all
right I'm going to go 7.5 whoa I'm the one sitting
in why you asked me first see the shill negative
all right John's the highest John's the highest
one here that's right all right go John I won't
drink my CH go uh no I mean like this episode
definitely had uh a slightly more um what am I
trying to say say like the the plot beats of this
episode do maybe feel a bit like oh crap we're
already dealing with certain things but um I've
just been so enthralled by the atmosphere they've
been going for the tone the the percolating dread
but just the general sense of like something is
off something is wrong I we can't tell what it is
but it's something close by it's something in the
room I think they're good at drawing that air of
mystery and that air of paranoia and uh and and
immediacy for this and so uh yeah like the whole
fun like I thought it was a really fun game with
Brad that ultimately led into and paid off with
everything with Sylvia and now it seems like we're
certainly kind of getting off to it's like I feel
like the first episode established like the tonal
and the broader Stakes of the season and now this
episode seemed like it's kind of honing in on like
some of the more immediate Stakes um and so yeah
like you know there are certain plot beats I think
could have been maybe a little a bit a little bit
more smooth um but you know as just an unfolding
chapter of this journey I'm couldn't be more
enthralled and I love the prospect of Casey and
Ora Boris you know like working together and all
those things uh yeah there's there's so much to
this episode that I loved so anything that was
maybe a little bit like that I might have been
a little taken a back by timing wise you know was
all pretty much compensated for in other ways and
in some moments of true tension and true thrill
and all that stuff so that's a fair point Fair
Point Asian persuasion that's right OB and Casey
right uh Kon I thought yeah that referring to me
as the Asian persuasion I was very confused then
was Kon now we're back to confusion I uh I dropped
it down a little because I the first episode's
like a I didn't know we were using decimals
but first episode if decimal would be like a 98
like first episode was damn near perfect for me
uh I did find this episode it had to do some time
jumps in order to make the mystery work and I did
find that undermind the stakes for my experience
personally uh like I would have preferred to have
a little bit more coherence between leaving and
then Brad jumping in and I understood that that
is how the mystery unraveled and how they made
it all work but it did feel like by the time we
got to the stakes there was only 5 minutes the
episode left and the weight of the prune felt
like wait out of nowhere that's what they're
doing like the timeline of the episode didn't
seem to line up with the timeline of the things
happening like there was the mystery of Sylvie
there was his nervousness and then it was like we
have to make sure it has Stakes all of a sudden
it's like they're pruning immediately and the
causality of their mission didn't seem to line
up with the actual events occurring like I I think
that that would have occurred whether the mystery
happened or not it it was like that was happening
in another room so it would have still been unless
they solved it a little faster it just it the jux
position of the the a plot and B plot felt like
it left some to be desired in a big enough way to
drop it a two uh point system for me I loved the
scenes uh of like just two people talking like
I always do with the show I really enjoyed the
pi scene really enjoyed seeing Rafael casselle
get to like act uh his eyeballs out opposite Tom
Heston that scene um of them playing like chess
mentally was a blast I did go from Owen Wilson is
pretending to him actually being afraid Loki was
going to get away with something uh I thought the
Mischief had had actually gotten to the point
where Loki might have done something evil and
like Mobius have been like only go this far and
then he went further that that was what I meant
by like him pushing him so I it's just something
felt not quite as tight as the First episodes like
Precision this did feel like it was a 10-minute
longer edit that was missing some things that
built the tension more naturally enough that it
dropped down some for me yeah um I I agree with
everyone's points I do agree with with everything
you guys are saying uh this I love the acting in
it um that was like probably my favorite aspect of
it the acting in particular was great what's that
actor's name that you love Rafael Cassell Raphael
dude blind spotting if you've never seen blind
spotting that's where he's yeah dude damn I could
not place it he's guy off the they're like they go
way back into the bay together they they've been
making music and movies together forever not place
it dude I love that guy well that makes a lot
more sense now because one thing I was I I think
I said it out loud was I was there should be more
rapping yeah it was like there's the Rhymes uh it
was the the the rhythm of the dialog yeah no like
the there's there is such great scene work with
the Rhythm and the back and forth and I like how
a lot of this just feels like actual scene workor
with a true true life to it you know what going
back to like secret Invasion that was one of the
compliments we would give it but here there's
actual like it's more like jazz and this time
around you know I feel like Kevin feige watched a
bunch of movies he liked he was like all right we
got everything every all at once is OB we got
a blind spotting like I feel like he watched
St like let's bring them into Marvel yeah yeah I
mean and the cinematography again does still stay
consistent in terms of really shining there's
a lot of awesome symmetry throughout uh but I I
was taken aback by is I thought when we first saw
we first saw him as the actro I was like oh this
must be his life before he was turned you know a
very think that was an intentional mislead yeah
I thought that's what it was going to be and then
oh he just was has been here and then to go from
the first episode where it was really if you kind
of the only example I'm going to do this is not
really a comparison it's really just to to present
an example if you look at the first season you
know one thing to get us um focused was we need
to find out who is this Hunter who this mysterious
Hunter who's killing other variants right that was
like the the main mission at hand as we grow out
the rest of the Mysteries in the world and then
the last episode was really focused on chaos is
happening King is coming he who remains other
variants of him are coming and I actually feel
like this episode started kind of losing sight of
that focus and started becoming about like what
are these other TVA members doing and it it weird
is they're they're they're providing these like
melancholic moments and and these like harrowing
bits especially towards the end that conceptually
yeah do sound like really Bleak and dire uh but
it doesn't really hit when it at the end of the
day I am just look as an audience I'm just there's
a lot I'm keeping up with and there's a lot that
I'm paying attention to and I'm just looking at a
line of you know per like that's what I mean the
acting is really good yeah like from B15 everyone
is great in that moment um but I I'm like sure
it is it is that kind of like jaded thing that a
lot of us feel like with with real life news you
know yeah when you get inundated with stimuli and
you're like okay 72 people died you don't feel the
weight of the 72 people much l billions yeah yeah
I mean as as messed up as it is to say something
like that it's just the truth of the matter and so
to me there were just things about the pacing that
were just feeling a little bit questionable to me
towards especially towards the end because like
they really took their time with interrogating
Brad so they really took their time there I feel
like they saw the gold they had and then the
episode had to be a certain link so they cut
other like it just felt like pay strong and it's
like they introduced like the TVA is what they're
really doing Doc is doing this and okay I guess
they they took care they took out them really
fast these are the end of her loyalists I'm like
but there's no real waight to hear we just kind
of feel like we just kind of rushed through this
and now we're supposed to feel this like gravit
this gravity of the all these deaths of that just
happened there was no real build yeah there was
no real buildup into it this episode had two this
felt like two episodes worth of major plot lines
leil into one because you could have done all
the Brad like the Brad stuff started to feel to
me kind of like it could have flirted with being
akin to that She-Hulk episode where she goes and
sees Donnie Blaze could have this it but then get
that battle at the end and that is a huge piece of
stakes and I think yeah seeing the Lions shrivel
up would have hit a lot harder in an episode about
that yeah if it was if it was a race against to
prevent that if the episode was focused on that
CU we didn't even know that was our race yeah
we didn't even know until 5 minutes before the
ticking clock just ended like we got to the 11th
Hour of a ticket I thought it was going to end
on the Cliffhanger of that episod was like okay I
guess this just happened and I'm like okay now we
got a whole new bag of worms we got to deal with
um but so much work that I can't drop it below a
seven but that's hu no yeah I I would still recom
I I still liked it uh because there's there's so
many great acting moments in here and while the
emotional beasts maybe don't hit as strong and I I
mean I was never quite believing it was like yeah
we know Brad's eventually going to give up the
information so I like that they're taking their
time and against really good scam workor um and
and I like what they're setting up especially
with Mobius of him discovering his past and
and the asking the existential questions and the
Flippo too like you know some of the most talked
about moments of season 1 was them just sitting
across from each other having conversations about
the philosophies of life and existence and purpose
and what and and then you know that I I like the
lived in conversation that Mobius is presenting
about you know if I'm bad my life before I'm bad
I could live with that but if I'm good like oh
I'd be missing there's like that fear missing out
I thought that was really strong and more comp
telling you know as opposed to the opposite of
but if I'm bad do I want to know that like oh
know that it would mess with you you was like
but I have a purpose here as mobus if that was
the ab plot I would have been really happy with
this episode and then I like the idea of ending
on a cliffhanger and then starting the episode
with the ramification so you have the weight to it
it's literally like make this episode 40 minutes
without the last 10 and then open like I just
the pacing really changed the stakes for me this
this was interesting cuz cuz I thought like the
character and the like the the tonal the spiritual
writing was really good but yeah like the the nuts
and bolts plot writing wasn't as good and uh I I
have some questions about Sylvie uh because
super there's no uh I feel like there should
be some level of accountability that she's not
taken at all like whatsoever I think that's her
being and Loki doesn't even seem at all perturbed
by like hey like that would have been the first
like there's a lot happening because you chose you
chose to do this you Ked me out you know I think
she's keeping him at and he's just like still
soft yeah I think that damn will break I hope so
I don't really feel an intense I don't really feel
like there's anything building within Loki about
that what she did but I do feel like I I felt a
lot of that initial sort of like shy I mean like
there's all of that history there but also like
I don't want to mess this situation up because
there's probably a hope of rekindling some of that
from before so you don't want to just charge in
Gung oh like you know your accountability for
this chaos that's raining right now yeah he's
trying to fix the relationship before he's like
we talk about that thing if they don't unpack
that though I would be upset yes if it doesn't
happen in the next coming episodes but like just
getting her back just having them meet like I I
kind of expected it to be like yeah there will
be other stuff at hand this episode and they'll
have tension but that'll get resolved later but I
can understand you wanting it just because it is
such a huge deal and it is like it is affecting
all of of time and space essentially so part of
me is like yeah it's fair to expect somebody to
just jump out and be like you realize what's
happening right now I do hope the next episode
is about their relationship enough to flesh out
those issues and to ground things a bit more and
and then I guess the last thing to think about um
I mean I don't really want to spend too much time
on it is when you are seeing the craziness that's
happening across the Multiverse I can't help but
go has has this been affecting stuff that was
happening in phase four you know I still think
that there's multiple timelines we've met yeah I
still I mean one of those prune timelines might
be like when the only place the celestials exist
where that guy is sticking out of the SE I love
that movie but nobody else did so let's prune
the eternals don't worry don't worry it's on its
own timeline the whole universe maybe not anymore
they just got qu I got question it's like you got
to at the end of the day because it's connected
conceptually that's all the sacred timeline which
is what's safe conceptually sure but I do think
there's going to be a discovery of there being
multiple timelines that we have already met yeah
and I think Deadpool's going to deal with that all
right well still overall plenty to really like um
but and and I think the the parts of it that don't
hit it as strong only really cast a a shadow
because the first episode was so strong that
when something's not quite clicking you're like
okay is not bad I just noticed yeah yeah still if
it was Rotten Tomatoes you would still be like
that's still fresh still fresh still fresh you
say seven out of 10 you're like whoa low but
if you're like 70% right like freshman s out
of 10 is deceptive cuz seven out of 10 is like
that's pretty good but if you go like by school
rating like that's a c Andy that's average we
have a public education system problem in this
country it's an average score yes all right guys
we'll leave your thoughts Down Below on what you
thought of Loki season 2 episode 2 uh thank you so
much for being here but before we exit out let's
do a p all right John we got to play catchup here
since we're behind on shout outs and there's only
so many days left in the mon we got to shout out
two patrons of course I have an idea I want to
see how strong chat gbt would be at replacing
a generated script here excellent so I'm going
to need you to pick two people here all right all
right here we go let's do uh let's do David Gandy
okay and let's do adilia Chamberlain David Gandy
and Adelia Chamberlain all right but we're gonna
need to give chatti UT some information about what
we know they've been patrons for a very long time
so we we've gotten to know them quite a bit sure
all right so how would you describe okay hold on a
second um I need to I need you to create a scene
um of two characters interacting just want the
dialogue just want the dialogue stomia if you will
a what stick athia is a script where it's just
dialogue you knew I would not know what that is
stick ayia you don't have to tell you don't it's
fine SP how you spell that [__] how to spell
it jeez only say words you know how to spell okay
God a simia if you will and you will here's their
personalities all right let's go with David Gandy
how would you describe David Gandy David Gandy is
uh soft spoken calm and collected calm collected
uh uh he's uh selfless selfless very caring
plays guitar does martial arts does martial arts
photographer photographer MH and lives in Arizona
got hella action figures got a bunch of action
figures loves old movies yeah Cinema copile copile
what do you think David Gandy would be dressed up
as on Halloween oh David Gandy would be dressed
up as Indiana Jones dressed up as Indiana Jones
for Halloween now Adelia Chamberlain how would you
describe personality Adelia Chamberlain is um uh
fiercely loyal fiercely loyal she's uh resourceful
and intelligent resourceful intelligent creative
creative just likes to write loves to read books
yes liberal yeah has a good moral compass strong
moral compass yeah shy shy yeah um uh but also uh
geeky definitely attentive but also like really
into a lot of different uh pop culture things
copile as well loves Dune also copile what would
she be for Halloween oh um uh uh what's her name
elasa girl elast she dressed as elasa girl from
from yeah The Incredibles from The Incredibles for
Halloween alrighty here's their personalities and
have them meeting each other or catching up while
bumping into one another during trick or treaty o
yeah I love it let's see love this theme all right
setting a dimly lit Suburban Street lined with Old
Oaks and leaf covered sidewalks children laugh
and scream in the distance the soft glow from
lanterns and Jacko lanterns gives a hallowed
Ambience to the chilly Halloween evening all
right I'm going to play David all right I will
be adilia all right remember David is dressed as
Indiana Jones sure oh I'm sorry I didn't see you
there it's all right I was just lost in the world
of oracus in my mind you're Indiana Jones right
that I am and you elasa girl from The Incredibles
I appreciate appreciate the attention to detail
thank you it's one of my favorite movies Pixar's
Masterpiece if you ask me though you seem to have
a classic taste Harrison Ford in his pride I do
love the classics this compelling dialogue there's
a certain charm in old movies you ever sit down
with an old film reel and just lose yourself in
the monochrome world I love when characters talk
about themselves as characters uh absolutely
they have a Timeless Beauty although I'm more
of a bookworm there's something about that's
utterly captivating I can weirdly this is how
they would talk to each other I can understand
that I'd like to Capture Moments with my camera
Arizona Landscapes mostly but anything that
tells the story accurate uh Arizona that's far
from here what brought you to this neighborhood
tonight visiting family and I couldn't resist the
Allure of trick-or-treating in classic Suburbia
the Landscapes are one thing but the memories
they're something else I write to capture those
memories to build worlds and craft Tales but
speaking of stories you must have some Tales from
your Martial Arts Journey that I am very aware
of yeah it's all about balance much like the
strings of my guitar true oh yes thank you yeah
do you play any instruments no but I can craft
a narrative around I've always admired people
with a musical Touch by the way I couldn't help
but notice the action figures peing from your
back wow it's just like when Marvel's like insert
this yep let's give me that last line again John
yeah I just couldn't help notice the action
figures peeking from your bag as guilty as
charged they're all all for me I promise some
are for my younger cousins although I might be
keeping that vintage Han Solo like bued it's
all right we all have our inner geek speaking
of which have you read Dune only once but I've
watched the old movie adaptation a masterpiece
in its own right ah another point of connection
I believe this Halloween might just be the start
of a beautiful copile friendship with a Sprinkle
of geekiness on top too many more conversations
under the soft glow of movie projectors oh both
characters continue their Journey Down the Lane
there Silhouettes slowly merging into the evening
Haze bonded by their shared passions oh my God we
have everything to worry about AI replacing this
is all this is ready to go green light this now
this is Aaron Soren material at its Fest yeah man
this is going to be in theaters next week ah well
and now I know what it would be like if David and
Adelia ever met in person yeah [Music] definitely